stéphanie chouinard alec castonguay
christian dufour bonsoir
premier tour des élections françaises je
vais vouloir vous amener sur le terrain
ici en disant ce qu'il n'y a pas de ce
qu'on peut pas faire des rapprochements
avec la chute des grands partis
traditionnels mais d'abord je joue
faisons nous plaisir quand même un
premier tour de table sur je commence
avec vous christian sur les résultats
d'hier qu'est ce que ça vous a dit
moment il ya eu deux surprises parce que
les derniers sondages laissaient
présager que marine le pen et emmanuelle
bach ans serait dans un coude à coude
traître et c'est ce qui est arrivé
emmanuel macron surpasse nettement
marine le pen 4 à 5 points ce qui est
beaucoup et l'autre surprise c'est que
le leader de la française sourit
jean-luc mélenchon à gauche perform
beaucoup mieux que prévu donc la
conclusion que j'en tire c'est que c'est
une très bonne nouvelle pour emmanuel
macron qui est bien positionné pour le
deuxième tour c'est une déception pour
marine le pen soit dit rien décider pour
vous tous écoutent évidemment le débat
de l'entre-deux-tours que marine le pen
avait raté il ya cinq ans mais là pour
elle il faut quelqu'un qu'elle réussisse
oui c'est fanny
et bien on avait peur que le vote pour
le rassemblement national prenne de
l'ampleur considérant que contrairement
aux élections de 2017 y avait eric
zemmour qui se plaçait un peu plus à la
droite que marine le pen et que ça
puisse dédouaner dans un certain sens
les électeurs de la droite a voté
rassemblement national comme celui-ci on
vient de le dire ça ne s'est pas
matérialisée dans la façon dont on le
prévoyait
dans les sondages pré premier tour donc
une bonne nouvelle et ce sera
intéressant de voir surtout le vote mais
l'on mélange sont donc allés 22% qui ont
voté pour monsieur mélenchon est ce
qu'ils vont réellement aller vers
monsieur macron au deuxième tour où
est-ce qu'ils vont décider de rester à
la maison alec
pas pour ne pas répéter ce que mes
collègues m'ont dit je vous ai qu est ce
qui m'a le plus l'hypothèse
l'effondrement total des deux grands
partis historiques français qui depuis
1958 se partager le pouvoir jusqu'à
temps que emmanuel macron entre en scène
en 2010 est donc les par le parti
socialiste qui fait moins de 2% l'est
républicain ancien parti de nicolas
sarkozy qui fait moins de 5% c'est quand
même sa place les deux grands partis le
dans la catégorie des espèces en péril
sinon en voie de disparition l'a écouté
je crois même pas capable de se faire
rembourser leurs dépenses alors c'est
une catastrophe pour ces deux grands
partis le donc ce qui laisse toute la
voie emmanuel macron et aux autres
parties soient plus à droite ou plus à
gauche les extrêmes en gelée souvent dit
sont un peu comme un fer à cheval les
extrêmes alors à droite et à gauche on
se rejoint quelque part dans un anti
système un espèce de rhétorique en
système puis à droite et à gauche ça
vraiment été très très efficace alors
que les partis traditionnels un peu
comme ici dans le fond mais voilà je
manage arriver là alors poursuivre et la
tue pas précieux c'est fanny et et
christian mais un peu comme ici les
partis traditionnels
au québec parce qu'au fédéral il ya eu
réunion de la la droite envers eux ça va
tenir ça c'est une autre question c'est
le prochain sujet mais au québec
monsieur legault peu comme monsieur
macro qui est au centre gauche droite
laisse pas beaucoup de place à des
d'autres partis traditionnels
non mais ce qu'on a vu dans les derniers
mois c'est la montée d'éric duhaime le
parti conservateur du québec et pour un
parti traditionnel québec solidaire se
débrouille plutôt bien dans son créneau
à lui qui donc est né il ya pas si
longtemps non plus puis bon la caq on le
sait lost un jeu tourne à ces nouveaux
partis alors le parti québécois et le
parti libéral souffre beaucoup beaucoup
de faits qui sont là depuis longtemps
que les électeurs ont cherché de la
nouveauté mais aussi du spectre portée
capable de renouveler leurs discours de
trouver des terrains des jeunes étaient
au diapason alors c'est beaucoup plus
difficile pour eux au canada anglais ou
au fédéral faudra voir comment pierre
poilievre se débro il parce que c'est un
peu une tentative de d'harnachement du
parti conservateur traditionnel par la
droite populiste où on parle de crypto
monnaie on attaque la banque du canada
de toutes sortes de fantasmes le du côté
des poires pour bien pallié pisseurs
discours aussi en du système la
différence est qu'il est à l'intérieur
deux grands partis traditionnels mais il
s'essaie aussi à cette bague la lentille
système qui si populaire dans bien des
pays d'occident christian sur des
parallèles qu'on peut faire avec des
parties des vieux partis ici qui en
arrachent moi je serai réservé par
rapport à ces parallèles pour être franc
parce que le système français est
tellement fondamentalement différent du
système canadien et québécois en ce qui
a trait aux partis comme tel on sait que
dans notre régime parlementaire de sites
britanniques tout repose sur le parti le
premier ministre est pas élu par
l'ensemble de la population c'est le
chef du parti qui contrôle la chambre si
monsieur legault avait le malheur de
nous quitter cette nuit ce que je ne
souhaite pas du tout le premier bus du
québec demain après-midi ce serait
l'homme ou la femme qui serait choisi
par la cac donc il ya un renouvellement
des partis mais il semble que le système
des partis me semble encore très
vigoureux en france c'est complètement
autre chose c'est que depuis qu'on ne me
faire au septennat pour passer au
quinquennat depuis que les élections
l'élection présidentielle qui est la
grande élection en france c'est là que
le poids et coïncide avec les élections
législatives le somme des parties est
asphyxié de plus en plus d'enfants les
socialistes le pli républicain c'est la
fin d'un processus comme tel cheval au
niveau national je parle pas au niveau
local ou régional quand ça vient de la
base mais en france le problème qui on
sait que les candidats à la
présidentielle autrement ça se faire
leur partie automatiquement c'est pas
solide ça vient pas de là bas c'est pas
restez donc mot nettement je trouve pas
qu'il y aura coup d'anthologie à faire
sur les anti système sur les vieux rêve
très bien stéphanie et vous
écoutez c'est certain qu'il ya peut-être
certains parallèles à faire au sein de
la société civile comme par exemple à
ottawa on a vu on a vu le convoi
monsieur macro ya quelques années on
fait face au gilet jaune par exemple qui
sont justement des mouvements qui émane
cette protestation la du système de
lentilles système mais c'est un peu un
cercle vicieux pour les nouveaux partis
politiques qui se crée c'est à dire
qu'ils devront faire face au système
éventuellement peut rentrer dans le
moule et là il ya déception et on
retourne dans le cycle donc c'est normal
ça fait partie des systèmes
démocratiques et un certain renouveau
qui se place sur l'échiquier à la gauche
comme à la droite mais éventuellement il
ya toujours un retard et on finit par
jamais s'en sont finalement donc on y
vient cette course à la direction du
parti conservateur est ce que ultima on
pourra recoller à les deux trois
factions de ce parti là c'est à voir je
vous fais entendre monsieur charest qui
était à tout le monde en parle hier et
qu'il a au début avait dit moi j'attaque
crée pas pour liège offert ma campagne
chacun va faire sa campagne bon ben là
ils attaquent monsieur poilievre sur les
crypto monnaie on en parlera après est
ce qu'on va entendre sur l'appui que
donner pierre poilievre aux camionneurs
à ottawa
honnêtement quand j'observe la façon
dont il conduit sa course au leadership
je pense que des enjeux du jugement vous
donner un exemple qu'un élu l'a fait des
camionneurs sur la colline parlementaire
lui même blocus monsieur paul hier à
appuyer soutenu un blocus qui a eu des
conséquences très direct sur l'économie
canadienne qui était illégal et le il
fait la promotion de la crypte romane
est inattaquable banque du canada la
monnaie canadienne et moi j'essaie de
suivre et de comprendre et honnêtement
je trouve que c'est c'est plutôt
inquiétant comme comme proposition pour
pour le pays
alec il voit attaquer de plus en plus
monsieur poil hier parce que d'abord ce
poil hier lui ne s'est jamais gêné mais
parce qu'il voit bien là qu'il faut
qu'ils rattrapent du du terrain perdu
aussi et c'est une stratégie délibérée
c'est pas un hasard qu'un jean charest
se soient animés à cette question là moi
j'ai reçu jean charest mon émission
vendredi ç'avait été une entrevue tout à
fait classique d'aspirants la chefferie
et conservatrice quelqu'un qui veut
devenir premier ministre jusqu'à tendre
pierre poilievre arrive dans la
conversation éclat il se met à voir le
lui un peu comme on l'a vu à tout le
monde en parle c'est ça le stimule l'on
ne jean charest veut plus bagarreur
celui qu'on a connu en politique un peu
moins et 1 que les dernières semaines et
je pense que ça lui sert mieux et les
ici qu'il faut qu'il soit le français y
fassent des clairement bien poêle y
avait en tête il faut qu'ils gagnent du
terrain et oui tiens poliet fait ça
parlait de crypto monnaie parler de
convoi de la liberté parce que il veut
aller chercher les libertariens il a
fait bras peut être un peu plus
libertarienne du parti conservateur
bienvenue des nouveaux noms mais c'est
ce qu'ils cherchent à faire en même
temps chez les conservateurs il ya
encore une grande base qui est très
traditionnelle conservatrice comme le
dit non qui est probablement un peu
incertaine de 800 voix avec un kit au
moulin les attaques contre la banque du
canada et de la loi et l'ordre soit pas
une priorité de pierre poilievre danger
dans ces régions et occupation mais un
moment donné c'est qu'à aller chercher
d'une frange pour s'assurer de gagner ou
d'aller chercher des nouveaux membres
pour s'assurer de gagner peu s'aliéner
une partie de la base plus traditionnels
dont jean charest a absolument besoin
pour gagner c'est sa seule base et lui
ne peut pas aller jouer dans les mêmes
plates bandes des pierres mollien ville
c'est pas un populiste de nature jean
charest sur cette source des questions
là donc qui doit le l'attaqué doit faire
comprendre concerne de quel personnage
pierre poilievre et l'oeil le temps
commence à presser les des bosses s'en
vient je pense qu'ils placent la table
pour les deux débats de
stéphanie c'est intéressant parce que
poilievre choisi effectivement des
symboles forts dans plusieurs
communautés l'écriture monnaie c'est un
passé moi l'expression mais c'est un
besoin de gratter il sait qu'il va aller
capter l'attention il n'a qu'à dire ça
mais on a dit pas tellement en plus il
va chercher des adeptes
où est donc la crypto monnaie pour
régler le problème de l'inflation
on pourrait
lui poser les travaux si francis laffon
c'est nous je pense qu'on connaissait sa
réponse mais effectivement c'est
intéressant de voir à quel point
monsieur quoi il y avait monsieur
charest s'en vont dans des directions
fondement allemands opposés dans cette
course c'est à dire que sur le relief se
veut un candidat plus radicale qui va
même touché peut-être aller ali tenté de
tendre la main aux électeurs
conservateurs qui ont quitté le parti
conservateur avec maxime bernier tandis
que monsieur charest lui s'en voit
vraiment plus vers le centre va tenter
d'aller chercher le vote des des
libéraux bleus finalement des gens qui
sont peut-être un peu tannés du règne
libéral à ottawa mais qui ne sont
certainement pas prêts à embarquer dans
le wagon avec pierre poilievre est donc
pour le moment si on en croit les foules
que monsieur poilievre attire sur le
terrain c'est sa stratégie qui
fonctionne mais il reste quand même des
membres du parti conservateur de longue
date qui eux doivent être en réflexion
profonde actuellement on va écrire que
cela vous inspire ces deux personnalités
discours et propositions fort différent
au moins on peut comprendre leur
français c'est déjà un progrès parce que
souvent on fait là faut faire des
efforts on faisait semblant de
comprendre mais plus sérieusement ça pue
la quadrature du cercle parce que d'un
côté on a quelqu'un qui représente la
droite du radical à l'américaine l'autre
côté on a pris six mois un progressiste
conservateur à la preuve mais rooney
comment concilier les deux cela dit moi
je dois dire que j'écoutais l'introduit
à tout le monde en parle depuis je
trouve c'était décevant son entrevue le
parce que c'est bien beau d'avoir le pit
ont collé sur le passé puis machuret
mais moi j'aurais aimé entendre monsieur
charest sur ce qu'il veut faire sur ce
qu'ils proposent sur l'avenir c'est
quand même important lapointe
différentes justin trudeau dans quelle
politique c'est ça c'est de m'assurer
moi je puisse avoir de ce jeu ce quelque
soit son nom ne pas parler assez je
trouve que monsieur charest tu es
frustré de ça je le comprends d'avoir
été frustré de soi parce que l'enjeu est
important moi je reçois de mon sens
parce que dans une démocratie libérale
c'est important qu'on ait au moins deux
grands partis pour avant de certains
d'alternance mais ne s'est pas fait
parce que il ya tellement un gros écart
entre les deux tendances sit in à savoir
comment ils vont conseiller ça comment
la synthèse doit se faire de façon
fonctionnelle très bien dure semaine
pour le gouvernement le go on a été
replongé
dans l'affreux histoire de et rennes la
semaine dernière avec tel détail tel os
qui savait quoi bon
je vous fais entendre monsieur legault
qui accuse l'opposition
d'avoir injustement
attaqué madame blais madame née cannes
alors que la nouvelle de leur départ a
été soit fuite est en tout cas rendu
public avant que les deux principales
intéressées ne le fasse on écoute tous
adieu de tenir des propos comme ça parce
qu'on a les partis d'opposition pendant
toute la semaine qu'ils ont blâmé
danielle mccann et marguerite blais puis
tout à coup viennent à la défense de
danielle mccann et marguerite blais mais
je peux vous assurer que c'est pour
personne de mon entourage qui a fait
couler cette information lors tout ce
triste le confesse de la petite
politique parce qu'un élection partielle
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut faire le
lien entre ce salissage l'inconnu sur
toute la semaine je trouve cela odieux
je trouve ça franchement leur petite
politique de bas étage
on attendait qu'un rapport de la coroner
va se veut sortir christian commentaires
rapides il faut monsieur monsieur
legault je trouve car dit elle même si
c'est un vieux vétéran de la politique
n'a évité réelle ou supposée c'est dans
la nature des choses que ça soit sale
c'est une élection partielle ça arrive
au bon moment pour les partis
d'opposition parce que ça rappelle que
la pandémie la gestion du gouvernement
le groupe 7 était bonne mais il ya eu
jeudi un élément de déshonneur québécois
qui s'incarne dans marguerite blais plus
madame me khan dont le bilan ses
positions du vc 2 donc ça sort au
mauvais moment pour monsieur legault je
le comprends parce que cette élection
partielle là ça peut donner le temps à
l'élection générale qui s'en vient mais
c'est normal c'est ça la politique c'est
un combat puis les adversaires attaque
le gouvernement où ça fait mal alec
françois legault y allait pas de main
morte non plus qu un etat dans les
parties et dans les autres positions à
l'époque est attaqué et c'est sûrement
les gouvernements précédents que soit
celui de jean charest ou de philippe
couillard donc lui si tu es capable
d'aller pour la jugulaire veille pense
qu'il se fait servir la même médecine
que lui fait à l'époque
ya pas de doute je pense la majorité de
la population on pense que le
gouvernement en fonction de ce qu'ils
savaient au moment où ça se produisait
au fait le mieux qu'ils pouvaient selon
marguerite blais que soit dernier le
mecam que soit le premier ministre dans
un contexte faut se rappeler de l'époque
qui était très turbulent la fin du mois
de mars avec beaucoup de serre ges et
leurs difficultés ce encore plus loin au
ch et celle des privés maintenant qu'on
a des détails comme ceux qui sortent qui
donne toujours plus de relief à cette
histoire là on sera encore pire
christian raison quel point c'est un
déshonneur à quel point c'est une
catastrophe
b oui l'opposition vos processus va pas
se priver d'un même manière qu'on va
chercher des anecdotes à longueur
d'année pour essayer d'incarner les
critiques le gouvernement connaît dans
la gestion de 6 ou de sa loge
effectivement il ya une question de
moment de tomber en bon français là il
est temps de l'élection partielle
d'aujourd'hui qui faisons en sorte que
c'était peut-être plus échevelé mais
quand en plus on savoir la zone hexion
général est que les parties voient bien
françois legault et en taille il faut
décocher foule tirés vers le bas alors
ils vont prendre une seule fois il plus
faible le plus faible c'est la gestion
des ch et celles dépendant la première
vague ouest et fanny vous êtes d'accord
que c'est inévitable dans le jeu
politique mais pas le jeu aux yeux
l'enjeu même au sens non c'est normal
que l'opposition pose des questions
difficiles ou s'il est parti
d'opposition vont faire feu de tout bois
si vous me passez l'expression ans a
donné que les nouvelles de la semaine
dernière lors ordonné un beau cadeau
pour les élections partielles dont marie
victorin d'autant plus qu'on est
présentement dans une sixième bague est
d'autant plus que la cac qui est allé
chercher une candidate qui sort du
milieu de la santé pour représenter dans
ce dans cette circonscription le et donc
ça aurait été franchement assez
difficile va gêner le pq et le parti
libéral du québec ne pas s'accrocher à
cette à cette histoire là et d'ailleurs
ça a fonctionné dans la dernière semaine
donc c'est peut-être au dieu du point de
vue de la carte mais dans l'opposition
il aurait fait exactement la même chose
voilà bon élection partielle d'un
marie-victorin d'ailleurs on va regarder
il va suivre en direct avec
ce soit
qui a le plus à perdre nous a le plus à
gagner je disais tout à l'heure tous les
stratèges on prend des notes ce soit en
est à six mois de la générale tour de
table christian un bon dieu bon moment
que je me suis beaucoup de choses en
fait parce que pour le pq c'est un
château fort depuis 35 ans puis un très
très bon candidat ce que le pq est mort
à ce point là bas ce que l'accueil qui
est en train de baisser ce point là à
skis éric duhaime est hélas une vraie
élection c'est sûr qu'une partiel on
sait que ça représente pas
fondamentalement mais c'est pour une
fois qu'on a une élection l'on va sur le
terrain les gens vont au dessus allez
voter que ça va donner très intéressant
cette part c'est l'homme au chapeau qui
opèrent à l'est qui a le plus à gagner
et on l'a beaucoup dit c'est un cliché
mais pour le pq ça serait dur de ne pas
garder ça
je pense que celui qui joue le plus gros
c'est le parti québécois parce qu'il
détient la circonscription parce qu'il a
trouvé un candidat de qualité et parce
que si on se demande où s'en va ce parti
lors se pose plus de questions tôt la
survie du pq que de ce fait de la cag
donc inévitablement on va regarder ce
que le parti québécois fait comme
performance au regard des lacs à coucy
qui a pas si longtemps été donné
vainqueur assez facilement je parle de
quelques mois on pensait que ça va être
une balade de printemps au prince
laurent mundi marie-victorin ce sera
paul caussade risque d'être assez serrée
entre ces deux partis là les autres sont
faut vraiment dans la course soyons bien
connaître on laboure garder avec une
loupe ça reste que c'est une course
entre la cac et le pq et ça va être
intéressant de voir sur la rive-sud dans
un conte et ip de banlieue près de
montréal où en sont les force à
l'approché des prochaines élections un
taux de participation de 25% à 16 heures
on va déjà battu l'eau et stéphanie il
reste quelques secondes
marie-victorin c'est pas une
circonscription baromètre c'est
définitivement le pécule qui a le plus à
perdre évidemment surtout considérant la
situation dans laquelle il se retrouve
déjà très clair merci bravo merci à vous
trois à très bientôt au revoir je crois
pouvoir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh